i've told you before that the word
socialist for the american right has
become just like a meaningless catch-all
insult
that doesn't actually have anything to
do with what socialism
is uh as a form of government as a form
of an economy socialism is in its
simplest form a system where ownership
of the means of production
is socialized there are different
versions of it we can debate
whether we should be for or against it
but socialism is socialism it's not
other stuff that you don't like
emma vaisland from tyt i hope i'm
pronouncing her last name correctly
interviewed a trump supporter and this
trump supporter
may be the dumbest trump supporter i
have ever seen interviewed period
and that takes a lot i mean it takes a
lot to even potentially get to that
level the woman that emma interviews
says
that joe biden is a socialist now of
course if you look at the democratic
field
you would realize that joe biden would
be the likely the furthest from the
socialist of those candidates currently
running in the democratic
pri primary um and emma
asks basic follow-up questions like what
do you mean joe biden's a socialist and
then it gets really good
if you're listening and not watching
just bear in mind that the woman is
wearing obviously
a red maga hat during the interview do
you think joe biden is a socialist
yes how would you define socialism
i define socially when you bring down
your own country
your own race because it's not black
and what does that mean bringing him
down to black people is that what you're
saying
no he's saying that the white people
he doesn't look at himself in the mirror
okay so it's already
insane he's a socialist because he's
bringing down
his own country and race and he's not
black what like what does that even mean
i'm not even understanding the language
that's being used never mind the
underlying
sentence sentiment that this woman is
trying to communicate let's continue she
tries
another definition and emma is actually
so perplexed by the stupidity of this
person she's visibly struggling to even
unpack this
and ask follow-up questions because you
can't unpack
complete and utter nonsense
so he that's what i look at hey
you talk about the white people and look
at you
oh he actually you know i don't like him
i'll tell you exactly why i don't like
him
he's got a big ego he thinks he's better
than god
you're trump trump said he could shoot
someone in the middle of fifth avenue
and get away with it
no i don't think so he did say that no
he didn't
no it's on tape no i don't believe it
that's fake i swear to god you can watch
him
news fake news okay this part is
actually really scary
trump obviously did say that he could
shoot someone on fifth avenue and not
lose support this is how the minds of
these people work
they hear something that they don't like
they just deny it exists and this is why
you can't reason with these people and
i'm going to say more about that later
fake news fake news
okay do you want to watch the video they
say i have the most loyal people did you
ever see that
where i could stand in the middle of
fifth avenue and shoot somebody and i
wouldn't lose any voters okay
it's like incredible any of the
democrats to any of them appeal to you
liars all liars the pinocchio keeps
growing
okay and then you yourself won't have a
country
you yourself won't have a country keep
believing all these
liars and you yourself will be out of
your country
socialism doesn't work wherever it goes
why is joe biden a socialist why is your
vine on socialism
he because it's all about the money i
mean
what socialism is about you know the
thing is that joe biden is
all about the money it's all about the
power the money
that's why trump's a billionaire yes and
so is joe biden
no yes yes yes
trump went bankrupt four times no he
didn't
no he didn't no he didn't and that's
business
but he did many people okay you go
bankrupt how many people do
don't start all over again after a
bankruptcy
so this is severe idiocy that's all i
mean this is not
this is not a person who's simply
mentally ill right that's not what we're
talking
about here sure there may be some
personality disorders going on there who
knows
but this is someone who's simply
severely brainwashed biden is a
socialist because he's all about the
money
and biden is a billionaire biden is of
course not a billionaire
and if he were a billionaire in a
country where most people can't even
meet a 400
expense that's unexpected he probably
would not be a socialist and the most
important takeaway i want you to glean
from this
is that we can't convince these people
that trump is toxic
that he's bad for the country that he's
bad for the world and not to vote for
him
you can't convince these people because
they reason
backwards facts have no effect on them
they come up with an idea
like biden's a socialist and they will
attribute to that
anything biden's a socialist because of
something about his race
biden's a socialist because he's all
about the money biden's a socialist
because he's a billionaire so when i say
don't worry about them i don't mean
don't worry about the fact that people
like this
are what got trump elected and have done
so much damage to this country what i
mean is
let's just get left wingers to vote it's
a much better campaign strategy and this
is an example of why
how long would it take you to convince
this woman to vote for someone other
than trump would it take
five hours would it take ten hours if we
got like the most influential and
effectively convincing
progressive minds in a room with this
woman would it take a hundred hours to
convince her to vote for someone other
than trump
how many people who already dislike
trump
but are sort of on the fence about
whether they want to vote at all could
we simply
talk to and say listen here's why you
should vote let's get you registered
here's why voting is important
i believe that in the time it would take
to convince this one woman to vote for
someone other than trump if it were even
possible
we could be convincing dozens or
hundreds of people
to vote for someone other than trump who
already are sensitive
to the anti-trump ideology so as i've
said before
i do a show right i believe in dialogue
emma
works for tyt it makes sense for her to
talk to this woman i take phone calls
from trumpists and from right wingers
but i'm doing a show right as a campaign
strategy as a get out the vote strategy
as a strategy to defeat donald trump in
2020
don't waste your time with these people
because there is no sense in it
you cannot convince them or if you could
it the amount of time it would take
would not make any sense to actually
spend okay
they're a lost cause for the purposes of
winning elections
the way we want to win them let me know
what you think i'm on twitter at d
pacman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show if you're watching on
youtube
please hit the subscribe button down
below
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out
the david pakman show today is sponsored
by skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
skillshare
when you click the link underneath this
video skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than twenty five thousand
video classes on just about
anything you can think of get better at
playing an instrument
learn to use photoshop how to edit
videos
they have classes on drawing painting
business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and i'm not even
really scratching the surface i recently
took a great class on
introductory watercolor painting
i'm still not good but i am learning and
you can access
the entire library of fun easy to use
online courses for free for two months
by using the link underneath this video
two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
i've gotten a ton out of it
pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable
and i think you'll love it too get
started for free by clicking the link
under this video